three years prominent voices said it had
been a secret conspiracy between the
president's campaign and a foreign
government but when the Muller
investigation and the Senate
Intelligence Committee debunked out the
D legitimizing endeavor didn't stop
didn't stop
remember what chairmanship said here on
the floor he suggested that if an
American that if the American people
reelect President Trump in November that
election will be presumptively invalid
as well that's chairmanship on this
floor saying if the American people rely
President Trump this November that
election will be presumptively invalid
as well so they still don't still don't
accept the American voters last decision
and now they're preparing to reject the
voters next decision if they don't like
the outcome not only the last decision
but the next decision heads we win tails
you cheated and who can trust our
democracy anyway they say this kind of
talk creates more fear and division that
our foreign adversaries could achieve in
their wildest dreams as dr. hill
testified our adversaries seek to divide
us against each other
degrade our institutions and destroy the
faith of the American people in our
democracy and as she noted if Americans
become consumed by partisan rancor we
can easily do that work for them the
architects of this impeachment claimed
they were defending norms and traditions
in reality it was an assault on both
first the house attacked its own
precedents on fairness and due process
and by rushing to use the impeachment
power as a political weapon of first
resort then there are articles attacked
the office of the presidency then they
attack the Senate and called us
treacherous then the far-left tried to
impune the Chief Justice for remaining
neutral during the trial and now and now
for the final act the Speaker of the
House is trying to steal the Senate's
sole power to render a verdict speaker
says she will just refuse to accept this
acquittal Speaker of the House says she
refuses to accept this acquittal
whatever that means perhaps you will
tear up the verdict like she tore up the
State of the Union address so I'll ask
my distinguished colleagues across the
aisle is this really really where you
want to go the president isn't the
president an acquittal isn't an
acquittal attack institutions until they
get their way even my colleagues you may
not agree with this president must see
the insanity of this logic it's like
saying you're so worried about a bull in
a china shop that you want to bulldoze
the china shop to chase it out and
here's the most troubling part the most
troubling part there is no sign this
attack on our institutions will end here
in recent months Democratic presidential
candidates and Senate leaders have toyed
with killing and filibuster so the
Senate could approve radical changes
with less
the liberation unless persuasion some of
our colleagues sent an extraordinary
brief to the Supreme Court threatening
political retribution if the justices
did not decide a case the way they
wanted we've seen proposals to turn the
FEC the regulator of elections and
political speech into a partisan body
for the first time ever all these things
mr. president all these things a toxic
temptation to stop debating policy
within our great American governing
traditions and instead declare a war on
the traditions themselves a war on the
traditions themselves so colleagues
whatever policy differences we may have
we should all agree this is precisely
the kind of recklessness the kind of
recklessness the Senate was created to
Scott the response to losing one
election cannot be to attack the office
of the presidency the response to losing
several elections cannot be to threaten
the electoral college the response to
losing a court case cannot be to
threaten the judiciary the response to
losing a vote cannot be to threaten the
Senate we simply cannot let factional
fever break our institutions it must
work the other way as Madison and
Hamilton intended the institutions must
break the fever rather than the other
way around
the framers built the Senate to keep
temporary rage from doing permanent
damage to our republic the framers built
the Senate
to keep temporary rage from doing
permanent damage to our republic that
mr. president it's what we will do when
we end this precedent breaking
impeachment I hope we will look back on
this vote and say this was the day the
fever began to break I hope we will not
say this was just the beginning
I ask unanimous consent the Senate stand
in recess subject to call the chair
without objection the Senate stands in
recess subject to the call of the chair
the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment if there's no objection the
journal of proceedings of the trial are
approved to date the deputy sergeant at
arms will make the proclamation hear ye
hear ye all persons are commanded to
keep silence on pain of imprisonment
while the Senate of the United States is
sitting for the trial of the articles of
impeachment exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States as
a reminder to everyone in the chamber as
well as those in the galleries
demonstrations of approval or
disapproval are prohibited the majority
leader is recognized the Chief Justice
the Senate is now ready to vote on the
articles of impeachment and after that
is done we will adjourn the court of
impeachment the clerk will now read the
first article of impeachment article 1
abuse of power the Constitution provides
that the House of Representatives quote
shall have the sole power of impeachment
unquote and that the president quote
shall be removed from office impeachment
for and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors close
quote and his conduct of the office of
President of the United States and in
violation of his constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
President of the United States and to
the best of his ability preserve protect
and defend the Constitution of the
United States and in violation of his
constitutional duty to take care that
the laws be faithfully executed Donald J
Trump has abused the powers of the
presidency in that using the powers of
his eye office President Trump solicited
the interference of a foreign government
Ukraine in the 2020 United States
presidential election he did so through
a scheme or course of conduct that
included soliciting the government of
Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations that would benefit his
re-election harm the election prospects
of a political opponent and influenced
the 2020 United States presidential
election to his
Vantage President Trump also sought to
pressure the government of Ukraine to
take these steps by conditioning
official United States government acts
of significant value to Ukraine on its
public announcement of the
investigations
president Trump engaged in this scheme
or course of conduct for corrupt
purposes in pursuit of personal
political benefit in doing so President
Trump used the powers of the presidency
and a manner that compromised the
national security of the United States
and undermine the integrity of the
United States democratic process he thus
ignored and entered the interests of the
nation president Trump engaged in this
scheme or course of conduct through the
following means one president Trump
acting both directly and through his
agents within and outside the United
States government correctly solicited
the government of Ukraine to publicly
announce investigations into a political
opponent former vice president Joseph R
Biden Jr and be a discredited theory
promoted by Russia alleging that Ukraine
rather than Russia interfered in the
2016 United States presidential election
- with the same corrupt motives
president Trump acting both directly and
through his agents within the outside of
the United States government conditioned
two official acts on the public
announcements that he had requested a
the release of 391 million dollars of
the United States taxpayer funds that
Congress had appropriated on a
bipartisan basis for the purpose of
providing vital military and security
assistance to Ukraine to oppose Russian
aggression in which President Trump had
ordered suspended and be a head of state
meeting at the White House which the
president of Ukraine sought to
demonstrate continued United States
support for the government of Ukraine in
the face of Russian aggression three
faced with the public revelation of his
actions president Trapp ultimately
released the military and security
assistance to the government of Ukraine
and has persisted in openly and
corruptly urging and soliciting Ukraine
to undertake investigations for his
personal political benefit these actions
were consistent with president Trump's
previous invitations
of foreign interference the United
States elections in all of this
president
Trump abused the powers of the
presidency by ignoring and injuring
national security and other vital
national interests to obtain an improper
personal political benefit
he has also betrayed the nation by
abusing his high office to enlist a
foreign power in corrupting democratic
elections where for president Trump by
such conduct has demonstrated that he
will remain a threat to national
security and the Constitution if allowed
to remain in office and has acted in a
manner grossly incompatible with self
governance and the rule of law
president Trump thus warrants
impeachment and trial removal from
office and disqualification to hold and
enjoy any office of Honor trust or
profit under under the United States
each senator when his or her name is
called will stand in his or her place
and vote guilty or not guilty as
required by rule 23 of the Senate rules
on impeachment article 1 section 3
Clause 6 of the Constitution regarding
the vote required for conviction on
impeachment provides that no person
shall be convicted without the
concurrence of two-thirds of the members
present the question is on the first
article of impeachment senators house au
is the respondent Donald John Trump
guilty or not guilty a roll call vote is
required the clerk will call the roll
mr. Alexander mr. Alexander not guilty
miss Baldwin miss Baldwin guilty mr.
Barroso mr. Barroso
not guilty mr. Bennett mr. Bennett
guilty mrs. Blackburn mrs. Blackburn not
guilty mr. Blumenthal mr. Blumenthal
guilty mr. blunt mr. blunt not guilty
mr. Bowker mr. Booker guilty mr. Boozman
mr. Bozeman not guilty mr. Braun mr.
Braun not guilty mr. Brown mr. Brown
guilty mr. Berger
mr. burr not guilty Miss Cantwell Miss
Cantwell guilty mrs. capito mrs. capito
not guilty mr. Cardin mr. Cardin guilty
mr. Carper mr. Carper guilty mr. Casey
mr. Casey guilty mr. Cassidy mr. Cassidy
not guilty
miss Collins miss Collins not guilty mr.
Coons mr. Coons guilty mr. Cornyn mr.
Cornyn not guilty miss Cortez Masto miss
Cortez Masto guilty mr. Kahn mr. cotton
not guilty mr. Kramer
mr. Kramer not guilty
mr. Crapo mr. Crapo not guilty mr. Cruz
mr. Cruz not guilty mr. Danes mr. Danes
not guilty miss Duckworth miss Duckworth
guilty mr. Durban mr. Durban guilty mr.
NZ mr. NZ not guilty miss Ernst miss
Ernst not guilty mrs. Feinstein mrs.
Feinstein guilty mrs. Fisher mrs. Fisher
not guilty
mr. Gardner mr. Gardner not guilty
mrs. Gillibrand mrs. Gillibrand guilty
mr. Graham mr. Graham not guilty mr.
Grassley mr. Grassley not guilty miss
Harris miss Harris guilty miss Hassan
miss Hassan guilty mr. Hawley
mr. Hawley not guilty mr. Heinrich mr.
Heinrich guilty mr. onoe mr. Ono guilty
mr. Hoeven mr. Hoeven not guilty mrs.
Hyde Smith mrs. Hyde Smith not guilty
mr. Inhofe mr. Inhofe not guilty mr.
Johnson mr. Johnson not guilty mr. Jones
mr. Jones guilty mr. Caine mr. Caine
guilty mr. Kennedy mr. Kennedy not
guilty mr. king mr. king guilty miss
clove achar miss clove achar guilty mr.
Lankford mr. Lankford not guilty mr.
lahey mr. Lahey guilty mr. Lee mr. Lee
not guilty mrs. Lafleur mrs. Lafleur
not guilty mr. mansion mr. mansion
guilty mr. markey mr. markey guilty mr.
MacConnell mr. MacConnell not guilty
miss mcsalley miss mcsalley not guilty
mr. Menendez
mr. Menendez guilty mr. Merkley mr.
Merkley guilty mr. Moran mr. Moran not
guilty miss Murkowski mr. Murkowski not
guilty mr. Murphy mr. Murphy guilty mrs.
Marie mrs. Marie guilty mr. Paul mr.
Paul not guilty mr. Purdue mr. Purdue
not guilty mr. Peters
mr. Peters guilty mr. Portman mr.
Portman not guilty
mr. Reede mr. Reede guilty mr. rish mr.
rishe not guilty mr. roberts mr. roberts
not guilty mr. Romney mr. Romney guilty
mr. Rosen miss Rosen guilty mr. rounds
mr. rounds not guilty mr. Rubio mr.
Rubio not guilty Mr Sanders
mr. Sanders guilty mr. says mr. SAS not
guilty mr. schat's mr. schat's
guilty mr. Schumer mr. Schumer guilty
mr. Scott of Florida mr. Scott of
Florida not guilty
mr. Scott of South Carolina mr. Scott of
South Carolina not guilty mr. Shaheen
mrs. Shaheen guilty mr. Shelby mr.
Shelby not guilty
miss cinema miss cinema guilty Miss
Smith Miss Smith
guilty miss Stabenow miss Stabenow
guilty mr. Sullivan mr. Sullivan not
guilty mr. Chester mr. tester guilty mr.
Thoon mr. Thoon not guilty mr. Tillis
mr. Tillis not guilty mr. Toomy mr.
Toomy not guilty mr. Udall mr. Udall
guilty mr. Van Hollen mr. Van Hollen
guilty mr. Warner
mr. Warner guilty miss Warren miss
Warren guilty mr. Whitehouse mr.
Whitehouse guilty mr. wicker mr. wicker
not guilty mr. Wyden mr. Wyden guilty
mr. young mr. young not guilty
you
this article of impeachment 48 senators
have pronounced Donald John Trump
President of the United States guilty as
charged
52 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty
the senator judges that the respondent
Donald John Trump President of the
United States is not guilty as charged
in the first article of impeachment the
clerk will read the second article of
impeachment article 2 obstruction of
Congress the Constitution provides that
the House of Representatives shall have
the sole power of impeachment and that
the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment floor and
conviction of treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors in his
conduct of the office of the President
of the United States and in violation of
his constitutional oath faithfully to
execute the office of President of the
United States and to the best of his
ability preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States and in
violation of his constitutional duty to
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed Donald J Trump has directed the
unprecedented categorical and
indiscriminant defiance of subpoenas
issued by the House of Representatives
pursuant to its sole power of
impeachment President Trump has abused
the powers of the presidency in a manner
offensive to and subversive of the
Constitution in that the House of
Representatives has engaged in an
impeachment inquiry focused on president
Trump's corrupt solicitation of the
government of Ukraine to interfere in
the 2020 United States presidential
election as part of this impeachment
inquiry the committee's undertaking the
investigation serves subpoenas seeking
documents and testimony deemed vital to
the inquiry from various executive
branch agencies and offices and cur
and former officials in response without
lawful cause or excuse
president Trump directed executive
branch agencies offices and officials
not to comply with those subpoenas
president Trump thus interposed the
powers of the presidency against the
lawful subpoenas of the House of
Representatives and assumed to himself
functions and judgments necessary to the
exercise of the sole power of
impeachment vested by the Constitution
in the House of Representatives
President Trump
abused the powers of his high office
through the following means one
directing the White House to defy a
lawful subpoena by withholding the
production of documents sought their end
by the committee's to directing other
executive branch agencies and offices to
defy lawful subpoenas and withhold the
production of documents and records from
the committee's in response to which the
Department of State Office of Management
and Budget Department of Energy and
Department of Defense refused to produce
a single document or record three
directing current and former executive
branch officials not to cooperate with
the committee's in response to which
nine administration officials defied
subpoenas for testimony namely John
Michael Mick Mulvaney Robert B Blair
John a Eisenberg Michael Ellis Kristen
Wells Griffith Russell T vog Michael
Duffy Bryan McCormack and T Ulrich Brett
ball these actions were consistent with
president Trump's previous efforts to
undermine United States government
investigations into foreign interference
in United States elections through these
actions president Trump saw to arrogate
to himself the right to determine the
propriety scope and nature of an
impeachment inquiry into his own conduct
as well as the you know a unilateral
prerogative to deny any and all
information to the House of
Representatives in the exercise of its
sole power of impeachment in the history
of the Republic no president has ever
ordered the complete defiance of an
impeachment inquiry or sought to
obstruct and impede so comprehensively
the ability of the House of
Representatives to investigate
high crimes and misdemeanors this abuse
of office served to cover up the
president's own repeated misconduct and
to seize and control the power of
impeachment and thus to nullify a vital
constitutional safeguard vested solely
in the House of Representatives in all
of this President Trump has acted in a
manner contrary to his trust as
president and subversive of the
constitutional government to the great
prejudice of the cause of law and
justice and to the manifest injury of
the people of the United States
wherefore President Trump by such
conduct has demonstrated that he will
remain a threat to the Constitution if
allowed to remain in office and has
acted in a manner grossly incompatible
with self governance and the rule of law
president Trump thus warrants
impeachment and trial removal from
office and disqualification to hold and
enjoy any office of Honor trust or
profit under the United States the
question is on the second article of
impeachment senators house au is the
respondent Donald John Trump guilty or
not guilty the clerk will call the roll
mr. Alexander not guilty Ms Baldwin
guilty mr. Barroso not guilty mr.
Bennett guilty mrs. Blackburn not guilty
mr. Blumenthal guilty mr. Blunt
not guilty mr. Booker
guilty mr. Bozeman not guilty mr. Braun
not guilty
mr. Braun guilty mr. burr not guilty
Miss Cantwell guilty
mrs. Capitao not guilty mr. Cardin
guilty mr. Carper guilty mr. Casey
guilty mr. Cassidy not guilty
ms Collins not guilty
mr. Coons guilty mr. Cornyn not guilty
miss Cortez Masto guilty mr. cotton not
guilty mr. Cramer not guilty mr krepo
not guilty mr. Cruze not guilty mr.
Danes not guilty miss Duckworth guilty
mr. Durbin guilty mr. Enzi not guilty
miss Ernst not guilty mrs. Feinstein
guilty mrs. Fisher not guilty mr.
Gardner
not guilty mrs. Gillibrand guilty mr.
Graham not guilty mr. Grassley not
guilty miss Harris
guilty miss Hassan guilty mr. Hawley not
guilty mr. Heinrich guilty mr. Ono
guilty mr. Hoeven not guilty mrs. Hyde
Smith not guilty mr. Inhofe not guilty
mr. Johnson not guilty
mr. Jones guilty mr. Caine guilty mr.
Kennedy not guilty mr. king
guilty miss Klobuchar guilty mr.
lankford not guilty mr. lahey guilty mr.
Lee not guilty
mrs. Leffler not guilty mr. mansion
guilty mr. markey guilty mr. MacConnell
not guilty ms mcsalley not guilty mr.
Menendez guilty mr. Merkley guilty mr.
Moran not guilty
ms Murkowski not guilty mr. Murphy
guilty mrs. Murray guilty mr. pawl not
guilty mr. Perdue not guilty mr. Peters
guilty mr. Portman not guilty mr. Reede
guilty mr. rish not guilty
mr. Roberts not guilty mr. Romney not
guilty Ms Rosen guilty mr. rounds not
guilty mr. Rubio not guilty Mr Sanders
guilty
mr. sass not guilty mr. schat's guilty
mr. Schumer guilty mr. Scott of Florida
not guilty mr. Scott of South Carolina
not guilty mrs. Shaheen guilty mr.
Shelby not guilty miss cinema guilty
Miss Smith guilty miss stabenow guilty
mr. Sullivan not guilty mr. tester
guilty mr. foon not guilty mr. telus not
guilty mr. Toomy not guilty mr. Udall
guilty mr. Van Hollen guilty mr. Warner
guilty MS Warren guilty mr. Whitehouse
guilty mr. wicker not guilty mr. Wyden
guilty mr. young not guilty
on this article of impeachment 47
senators have pronounced Donald John
Trump President of the United States
guilty as charged
53 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty
the senator judges that respondent
Donald John Trump president of the
United States is not guilty as charged
in the second article of impeachment
the presiding officer directs judgment
to be entered in accordance with the
judgment of the Senate as follows the
Senate having tried Donald John Trump
President of the United States upon two
articles of impeachment exhibited
against him by the House of
Representatives and two-thirds of the
Senators present not having found him
guilty of the charges contained therein
it is therefore ordered and adjudged
that the said Donald John Trump be and
he is hereby acquitted of the charges in
said articles as chief justice the
majority leader is recognized I sent an
order to the desk clerk will report
ordered that the secretary be directed
to communicate to the Secretary of State
as provided by rule 23 of the rules of
procedure and practice in the Senate
when sitting on impeachment trials and
also to the House of Representatives the
judgment of the Senate in the case of
Donald John Trump and transmit a
certified copy of the judgment to each
without objection the order will be
entered mr. chief justice
the majority leader is recognized for
concludes I want to very quickly
acknowledge a few of the people who
helped the Senate fulfill our duty these
past weeks first and foremost I know my
colleagues join me in thanking Chief
Justice Roberts for presiding over the
Senate trial with a clear head steady
hand and the forbearance that this rare
occasion demands
we know full well that his presence is
our presiding officer came in addition
to not instead of his day job across the
street so the Senate thanks to chief
justice and his staff who helped him
perform this unique role like his
predecessor chief justice rehnquist the
Senate will be awarding Chief Justice
Roberts the golden gavel to commemorate
his time presiding over this body we
typically award this to new senators
after about a hundred hours in the chair
but I think we can agree the Chief
Justice has put in his due and then some
pages delivering to go
you very much of course there are
countless Senate professionals whose
efforts were essential I have more
thorough thanks to offer next week to
all of those teams from the Secretary of
the Senate's office to the
parliamentarians sergeant-at-arms team
and beyond but there are two more groups
I'd like to single out now first the two
different classes of Senate pages who
participated in this trial their
footwork and cool under pressure
literally kept the floor running our
current class came on board right in the
middle of the third presidential
impeachment trial in American history
and quickly found themselves
hand-delivering a hundred and eighty
question cards from senators desk to the
Dyess no pressure right guys so thank
you all very much for your good work
[Applause]
and second define men and women of the
Capitol Police
we know that the safety of our democracy
literally rests in their hands every
single day but the heightened measures
surrounding the trial meant even more
hours and even more work and even more
vigilance thank you all very much for
your service to this body and to the
country
[Applause]
the chair recognizes the Democratic
leader I joined the Republican leader in
thanking the personnel who aided the
Senate over the past several weeks
Capitol Police do an outstanding job
day-in day-out to protect the members of
this chamber their staffs the press and
everyone who works in and visits this
Capitol they were asked to work extra
shifts and in greater numbers to provide
additional security over the past three
weeks thank you to every one of them I
too would like to thank those wonderful
pages I so much enjoy you with your
serious faces walking down right here
and giving the Chief Justice our
questions as the leader noted the new
class of pages started midway in this
impeachment trial when you take a new
job you're usually given a few days to
take stock of things get up to speed
this class was given no such leeway but
they stepped right in didn't miss a beat
ferrying hundreds of questions from US
senators to the Chief Justice on
national television is not how most of
us spend our first week at work but they
did it with aplomb I'd also like to
extend my personal thank you to David
Houck the director of the Office of
accessibility services tyler Pumphrey
the supervisor and grace of the Ridgway
the wonderful director of capital
facilities everyone graces everyone
graces team on Grace's team worked so
hard to make sure we were ready for
impeachment gary richardson known
affectionately to us as tiny the chief
chamber attendant
Jim Hoover and the capper and the
cabinet shop who built new cabinets to
deprive us of the use of our electronics
and flip phones during the trial brenda
bird 1 brenda bird and her team did a
spectacular job of keeping the capitol
clean and Lydon Webb and his team will
move the furniture and then moved it
again and again and again grace we
appreciate all your hard work please
convey our sincerest thanks to your
staff
thank you all the whole staff for your
diligent work through many long days and
late nights during this very trying time
in our nation's history mr. Joe and the
chair also wishes to make a very brief
statement I would like to begin by
thanking the Majority Leader and the
Democratic leader for their support as I
attempted to carry out ill-defined
responsibilities in an unfamiliar
setting they ensured that I had the wise
counsel of the Senate itself through its
secretary and her legislative staff I am
especially grateful to the
parliamentarian and her deputy for their
unfailing patience and keen insight
I am likewise grateful to the
sergeant-at-arms and his staff for the
assistance and many courtesies that they
extended during my period of required
residency and thank you all for making
my presence here as comfortable as
possible
as I depart the chamber I do so with an
invitation to visit the court by long
tradition and in memory of the 135 years
we sat in this building we keep the
front row of the gallery in our court
room open for members of Congress who
might want to drop by to see an argument
or to escape one I also depart with
sincere good wishes as we carry out our
common commitment to the Constitution
through the distinct roles assigned to
us by that charter you have been
generous hosts and I look forward to
seeing you again under happier
circumstances
the majority leader I move that the
Senate sitting as a court of impeachment
on the Articles against Donald John
Trump adjourned Shaunie died without
objection the motion is agreed to the
Senate sitting as a court of impeachment
stands adjourned sine die
the presiding officer the deputy
sergeant at arms will escort the house
managers out of the Senate chamber
president
the majority leader I suggest yeah up to
the coral clerk will call the roll
mr. Alexander
[Music]